Angelina Jolie getting emotional as she
drops her son Maddox off at college the
mother-son duo was spotted at Yonsei
University in South Korea earlier this
week where the 18 year old is set to
attend in a clip posted by an Instagram
user the 44 year old actress can be seen
chatting with a group of people as her
eldest son with ex husband Brad Pitt
patiently stands by her side this seems
like a great school Angelina and Maddox
posed for a photo with the group they
were also caught on camera taking a tour
of the school a source previously
confirmed to et that Maddox plans to
study biochemistry at the South Korean
University adding that he was accepted
into other schools but chose Yonsei and
has been studying the Korean language to
prepare he's very studious he's very
much more than I am a second source told
et that maddux's 18th birthday was a
huge milestone for Jolie and she is so
proud of how wise he is beyond his years
he's got a wicked sense of humor and
he's very fun to be with the source adds
the actress has quote encouraged him to
travel non-stop to learn many languages
and now has plans for him to go to
university overseas according to our
source Maddox is very attached to his
mom and she's always stood by him I
don't know he's kind of you and your
children are your best friends is kind
of a it's a nice life
[Music]